michel onfray vous sortez du coc vite
dans vous avez salma dérouillée au mois
de novembre
est-ce que sortant de là vous êtes
toujours un fan du professeur raoul tu
t'es bon j'ai jamais vas-y vous avez été
un fort soutien pendant la première
partie de l'année de monsieur raoul fait
de roxy clan absolument tout au tout au
départ quand tout le monde nous disait
tout le contraire de tout il y avait un
médecin qui nous disait moi je soigne de
cette manière là n'est utilisé très bien
qu'à un moment donné où descartes dit
quand on est perdu dans la forêt il faut
prendre un cap et le tenir donc j'ai
défendu cette idée qu'un médecin puisse
soigner
vous savez j'ai fréquenté hélas les
hôpitaux pour plein de raisons que quand
il en sait plus ou moins mais à chaque
fois que je vais demander un avis à un
médecin c'était un avis différent
donc il ya un moment donné où il faut
s'arrêter à l'avis des médecins quand
tous les autres disent mais on sait pas
on soigne pas quelqu'un dit moi je fais
ça j'ai soutenu cet homme en disant il
m'intéresse et c'est pas moi qui suis
allé vers lui j'avais pas encore parler
de lui que c'est lui qui est venu vers
moi pour que nous parlions de cet arbre
ensuite j'ai pensé que sur un certain
nombre de sujets il a eu tort
ouais le droit d'avoir tort jeter sur ce
sujet tout le monde a tout dit le
contraire de tout quand on parle
beaucoup comme c'est mon karma veut dire
beaucoup de bêtises par exemple c'était
une grippette avait il dit qu'ils ne
feraient pas plus de morts que que les
accidents de trottinettes un million et
demi sur la planète
je pense pas que la trottinette et
autant tuer il nous avait dit a
évidemment pas de seconde va qu'on est
en train de quitter la troisième et
c'est donc à un moment donné où quand on
s'est trompé on doit dire bon si je me
suis trompé mais le l'idée de dire je ne
me suis pas trompé puisque ce que j'ai
dit je n'ai pas dit ça ça me gêne un peu
par exemple vous n'avez pas été soignées
à l'hydroxyde lance alors dans l'est ont
sorti le oui/non classiquement oui mais
ça je peux je peux expliquer puis
quelques malveillants qui ont fait
savoir que la wii je défends d'élite
roxy chloroquine mais finalement quand
il s'agissait de moi je ne prenais pas
etc
il ya des médicaments qui ont des effets
secondaires tous les médicaments des
effets secondaires parmi les effets
secondaires de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
il ya ce qu'on appelle des torsade de
pointes de manière technique
c'est-à-dire des risques de créer des
infarctus j'ai eu un infarctus je suis
soigné pour ça depuis trente ans plus de
30 ans je prends des médicaments tire sa
compatibilité c'est une telle
incompatibilité que parmi les reee
pour moi de donner d'une prise de
lyderic cycle ans qui nie la mort donc à
un moment donné où j'ai vu ça avec mon
médecin et donc mon médecin a vu avec le
professeur raoul zeus elle n'a pas dit
très précisément même que le professeur
abdou regrette que mon médecin ait pris
cette décision mais nous avons médecins
et moins pris la décision de ne pas
utiliser l'hydroxyde cloaking parce que
je n'avais pas envie d'être un martyr de
l'hydroxyte le rocking d'autant plus que
lui ma 17 hydroxy chloroquine j'étais
très pur au départ parce que j'en avais
chez moi en cas de besoin personnel et
il me dit j'aurais un homme joel coville
aujourd'hui je pense que je n'utiliserai
pas à dire on a des études aujourd'hui
l'hydroxyde qui ne fonctionne pas bon ma
pensée dialectique
c'est à dire que tout au départ je
défends un homme qui nous dit mais moi
je soigne comme ça devienne que pourra
c'est ainsi je dis bah voilà quelqu'un
qui nous conduit c'est bien qu'on ait
besoin qu'on ait besoin d'être conduit
par un médecin quand on est malade on
soit on se remet à lui et puis le temps
passant se dit bon sur ce sujet ça va
pas sur celui ci non plus c'est un donc
je n'ai jamais été fan j'ai défendu
quelqu'un qui nous disait moi je soigne
de cette manière là les travaux étant ce
qu'il est c'est quand même quelqu'un
qu'on a beaucoup attaqué qu'on a
beaucoup appris ces cons à vous insulter
alors on a quand même fait des émissions
contre lui on a porté plainte etc
je persiste à croire que je redirai la
même chose dans la configuration d'il ya
un an et que ça n'est pas parce que je
n'ai pas pris d'hydroxyde le rock king
et d'ailleurs je les contacte et moi
même donc si j'avais pu médicalement
prendre je l'aurais évidemment prime